there was an argument in the car
it was an argument because i was ready
to go and everybody else wasn't ready to
go
but that's like normal friend stuff like
yeah we fuss about silly silly stuff all
the time
but
i never put my hands on anybody
i never
raised my voice too loud like this was
one of them times where it was like
it shouldn't have got this crazy
shouldn't have escalated that it did so
i get out the car and it's like
everything happens so fast
and all i hear is this man screaming and
he said dance [ __ ] and he started
shooting and i'm just like oh my god
like he shot a couple of times
so he's in the car shooting from the car
magazine is standing up over the window
okay shooting
and
i didn't even want to move
i didn't want to move too quick like
because i'm like oh my god if i take the
wrong step i don't know if he can shoot
something that's like
super important i don't know if he could
shoot me and kill me like were you
afraid for your life at that time i was
really scared because i had never been
shot at before